so i wanted to deliver this to you guys
you know from the perspective of healing
because as you get older as a dude
um it's like let's stop chasing women
let's chase excellence you know let's
talk about
you know what it's like to be be the
best version of yourself
as you're getting older because a lot of
guys out there there's some other bio
hackers out there i remember a couple
weeks ago there was um a video somebody
posted from
dave asprey i don't know if you you know
subscribe to his notion but
dude looks like [ __ ] these days like
dave aspley and i are not friends but i
will not disparage him on
okay well i'll say it because like i
watched the video
and i met him like 10 years ago and i
was like dude looks like [ __ ] and
he's the same age as me like like he's
within like born in the same
month as me right so right um i'm not
sure that i would trust his advice when
it comes to this
schedule and i was telling the guys and
grew up like listen up you know i'm
going to be doing something with jay on
on peptides in a few weeks so make sure
you watch that one because that'll have
everything you need
i mean when it comes to anti-aging stuff
i usually look towards ben greenfield
and you
um you're closer to my age in fact
you're older than me i think you're what
48 49.
uh i'm 49 i'll be 50. you're gonna be
getting an invite to the old 50th bath
right there dude i'm like five months
away all right
but um yeah man like you're looking good
for your age like i ran into you last
summer when i was in la you know we had
dinner and um
you know i remember looking at you going
and thinking to myself this guy
doesn't look like it like anywhere near
his age and he actually looks younger
than me even though he's older than me
right so
when it comes to anti-aging stuff again
you're the guy that i defer to so thanks
brother
you